as the coldest night of the year
approaches Britain is shivering Arctic
air dropping down from the north and set
to stay for days
it's putting pressure on our electricity
system the national grid for the first
time this winter activating emergency
coal units that have been standing by in
case of a shortage
the challenge we often face on very cold
days is getting through the short but
intense period of demand as everyone
gets home from work and school that's
millions of households putting the
kettle on turning the heating up and
making an evening meal all at the same
time
when it's windy we usually make more
than enough power to cover that but
right now it's relatively still
imports from Europe via subsea
connectors can also help but France a
major partner has had limited supplies
because of maintenance issues and
Strikes at nuclear plants
some of it was actually running through
the night last night Cole came to the
rescue this time but it is the dirtiest
of fossil fuels and has no future in the
UK's clean energy transition phased out
by the end of next year I'm actually
quite strongly against that we only
really have two Coal Power stations open
we do have a third this winter West
Burton but that's certainly going to
close in March I think it would be much
better to keep all of that open for as
long as possible and even to relax the
2024 dates I don't think that two Coal
Power stations are really moving the
dull when it comes to emissions but they
can be very important when we have
shortages such as the ones we're seeing
at the moment
this deep freeze a reminder that the
energy systems we rely on cannot be
taken for granted decarbonizing Power by
the middle of next decade as the
government has promised was never going
to be simple
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News